what do you say when people say
you know your exception to the rule most
people do not have
the ability to have their dreams come
true in america anymore like they once
used to
there are people i don't believe that
exists anymore so people are definitely
born into unequal privilege in society
that's that's
100 correct the issue at hand is not
can we make everybody who is unequally
privileged or who is unequally
privileged
equally privileged that would just be
socialism the issue is can we provide
enough opportunity
for the people who are less privileged
to be able to succeed in this country if
they
really desire to and my answer to that
is definitively yes we have a lot of
structures in our country
they need work but that enable you to
really
achieve the american dream for example
the military just like what you said
just like what you said
black men and black people who joined
the military have
higher much higher career outcomes
business careers they graduate higher
rates of education
and if you build in that structure into
these people's lives
and some of these people are coming from
homes in which there wasn't structure
but you build in that sort of structure
in a person's life
and it is going to change their life
it's going to make them a lot more
successful
and that's just one of the structures
that we have in this country now one of
the structures that we have in this
country that is actually hurting
a lot of black and hispanic americans is
the welfare state
is the welfare state this sort of no no
questions asked we're going to give you
money
um kind of kind of philosophy is really
hurting a lot of people now you have
people advocating for a
universal basic income we're going to
give you money no matter how hard you
work or anything like that
that instills the wrong mindset in
people so that's actually causing people
to um
to to to really uh stay in the position
that they're in and be incentivized to
stay in the position that they're in
rather than get out
now when you say ubi you've got to be
careful there because the person that
talked about ubi a lot is a man who was
from taiwan
and you know his name is andrew yang and
so
you know it you know that may be a
friend of yours who
you know got that message and as an
entrepreneur he got
millions of people to buy into the
concept of universal basic income
but you don't you don't agree with ubi
no
no and and and here's why one it's going
to cause inflation
we've already seen like a form of ubi be
passed in during the covid pandemic
yeah you know and guess what food prices
are like 30 40 percent higher now gas
prices are higher
home prices are higher and that that's
causing inflation so inflation is going
to be higher but forget just the
economics
of it think about the the the
disincentivization of personal
responsibility that ubi creates
so if you like the sort of clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye-bye